[Music]
william is in tampa to start off this
hour hey william what's up
hey dave and george how are you guys
great man how can we help
um me and my wife are flipping a
investment property
and we are in contract and come to find
out the people purchasing the house are
in an extended stay
and they're paying them 3 500. now i had
the bright idea to let them move in
before they close and my wife instantly
said no
so we're not doing it philosophically i
know she's right but can you tell me
logically
why she's right
um
well she's not necessarily right
uh it's done all the time
that people move into properties uh or
to remain in properties after they sell
them
either one
you know but what you would have to do
is you would have to have a series of
check boxes that that made it wise okay
one is i'd want to be very sure of their
financing
okay that they're are they financing the
property that they're purchasing
yes okay i'd want to i want a lot of
details about that and know that they're
qualified their mortgage company needs
to give me a lot of assurances this deal
is closing
okay
two is i want a ridiculous deposit
okay that is refunded upon closing
like i don't know what's the property
selling for
315. okay like 10 000 15 000 bucks
that's what i'd call a ridiculous
deposit
okay but they get it back as long as
they close
right
yes
then the next thing is is obviously well
not obviously but the the other thing is
is there's a lease
a written agreement
that if they don't close by a certain
date they move out and they forfeit
their deposit
okay would you do a weekly lease or a
monthly lease well it would be it just
be a written document that gives the
terms of the lease which is how much
they're paying you how much the deposit
is and that that if they don't close by
x date they move out and forfeit their
deposit
okay
okay now if you've got a solid document
like that you've got a big butt deposit
like that and you've got real real good
assurance on these people are studs as
far as their finances go their financing
is going
then there's not much risk to this you
kind of almost hope they don't close and
you pocket 15 grand
okay
that makes sense
well
it does that's why i i wanted to do it
but when she doesn't want to do
something i i listen to that well i
listen to it too just just letting them
move in she's right i wouldn't do that
with no without those other three things
okay
but if they don't want to put up a
deposit good sit sit in the extended k
they don't want to sign a lease good sit
in the extended
uh stay i call extinct care
this is daycare
but the uh
um or if their finances look iffy then
yeah that would be she would be right in
any of those if you don't do at least
those three things okay i'll flip it on
its head i just did this only it was me
okay or something similar i sold my home
which was a multi-million dollar
property and the buyer part of the
agreement was i did it last year part of
the agreement was i got to stay there
rent free
for four months after i closed on it but
i i left them a big deposit
and we had a written agreement and then
we moved out and we got our deposit back
simple deal right but part of the
agreement was i stayed in a house that
they owned because we closed it and i
stayed in my old house four months after
closing
i mean you see what i'm doing
so that's a similar deal but it's a
seller deal rather than a buyer deal but
still that that's the process so the
whole thing george is covering
dodge your eyes cross your teeth
you know now are you doing that with any
of your sales are you moving yeah so the
the buyers of our current home are
allowing us to live there 10 days after
closing for free as part of the deal
yeah and so that's part of it and it's
all in the agreements and that it all
makes sense and if we don't close
there's ramifications and so you know
all of that makes sense when you have
your your eyes dotted your t's crossed
but when you just do it willy-nilly
without any agreements on the table
that's what you're getting his wife
would be right yeah and so those people
do that they just oh yeah whatever you
know and then you get into a problem
yeah you know so just make sure you do
your due diligence you've got the right
paperwork in place you've got the
agreements you feel good about the
closing